a local mother is speaking out after a
confrontation between
school staff and her 13 year old son
with autism over him
not wearing a mask chantelle myers is
hoping to raise some awareness about how
to engage with students with special
needs and
how to prevent a situation like this
from happening to other families
kate houston reports typical teenage boy
loves baseball
bacon cars water swimming
and he has autism chantal myers is the
mother to 13-year-old christian myers
who has autism
myers says the past year of distance
learning has been tough
he hasn't had any social interaction
hasn't been around a lot of typical
peers which
you know obviously he's regressed in the
last year
substantially this week all grades were
able to return to school on a hybrid
model
myers took these photos of christian as
he entered the school for the first time
in over a year then all of a sudden i
just hear somebody
yelling from around the corner mask mask
where is his mask he needs a mask
and i looked at christian because i was
like well
what's going on here he wasn't wearing a
mask christian won't wear a mask because
of sensory issues
the organization for autism research
says mask wearing has been a challenge
for people with autism throughout the
pandemic
and has led to other confrontations
initially myers was told by the school
she needed a doctor's note in order for
christian to be in class without a mask
later they clarified she would need to
modify his individualized education
program
i'm surprised that he handled it as well
as he did because
not coming back into the building you
know or not being there for a year
and then being hit with that aggressive
attitude
or you know it was just uncalled for and
unprofessional i think in response ccsd
referred channel 8 to the hybrid model
guide which says
in part that a student with a disability
that prevents them from wearing a mask
may qualify for accommodations but it
must be documented in the student's iep
if anybody's at home because their kiddo
you know has to wear a mask to school
there's options and i just would hate
for somebody to experience what we did
yesterday and
it could have been handled completely
different kate houston 8 news now
myers has scheduled an iep revision with
the school next week to allow
christian to not wear a mask in the
meantime he will head back to class
on monday with his cohort denise